Germany Germany's investment in Russia
hit its highest level in a decade last
year however a new survey of German
companies suggests something of a
lottery when it comes to operating in
the country a third of the firm's say
the business climate in Russia has
worsened over the past year but around
the same proportions say things have
improved key complaints are excessive
bureaucracy and a weak economy Russia's
economic growth of 1.7 percent in the
third quarter of this year is below
what's needed to meet President Putin's
target of expanding faster than the
global average by 2025 I'm now joined by
Matthias Chevys with the German Russian
Chamber of Commerce in Moscow but here's
how's business in Russia in generally
very good GDP is slow we expect only 1%
growth until the end of the year but our
companies manage to grow faster and even
much faster than the market so their
turnaround is growing and also their
profit in general you do these see this
also with a high investment number last
year in 18 it was 3.2 billion which is
the highest number for 10 years if you
compare the inflow and the outflow of
German capital into Russia and it was
the second biggest number since the
Soviet Union fell apart but if you look
at your survey that you have done
there's a bit of a discrepancy one third
of German businesses says business is
great and another third says it hasn't
improved at all and it's not good it
does it depend on the sector why is
there such a disparity we also have this
disparity as you name it in the policy
concerning economics of the Russian
government on the one hand we do see a
clear improvement of business climate if
you take the doing business service by
the World Bank in 2011 Russia was
ranking place 124 between Oh
none will require now they are placed 27
so part of the companies were happy they
do see this other companies they see
that we have again an increase in
bureaucracy and they see things like the
biggest u.s. investor mr. Kelly being
arrested and under house arrest this was
a man who was running around and saying
hey Russia is a great place to invest
come here and then he had to spend a
couple of months in jail and I 100 house
arrest so how did Russia manage to climb
up from place 120 something into the top
30 in ten years less than 10 years you
can now register your business extremely
quick Russia is now under the mountain
top 10 worldwide they do have some
improvement in difficult areas like
customs where they are still lagging
behind so point four point they were
working on this difficult matters very
briefly corruption still a problem
yes as simple as that thank you very
much much here said from their German
Russian Chamber of Commerce in Moscow
and we stay on the subject of Russia the
North stream to pipeline designed to
bring gas from Russia to Germany is
nearing completion the project has more
than a few critics the European
Commission the USA Poland and the Baltic
States all opposing the project some
fear that the EU will become too
dependent on Russian natural gas and
others feel they are just pawns in
Russia's power games loop mean in the
German state of mecklenburg-vorpommern
this is where the 1,200 kilometer long
Nord Stream two pipeline reaches the
German Baltic Sea coast soon natural gas
from Russia will be flowing towards
Western Europe Nord Stream two will
circumvent Ukraine gas market expert
Michael Oman says there's a very clear
reason for building the pipeline
naturally the Russian side always
insists that Nord Stream 2 wasn't built
to bypass Ukraine like Nord Stream
but I believe that's exactly why as
special ships they pipeline sections
just a few kilometers off the German
Baltic Sea coast resistances coming from
the US they are planning sanctions
possibly to include those operating the
vessels instead of natural gas from
Russia
the USA wants to sell its liquid gas
there's also opposition to the pipeline
in Poland its antitrust Authority has
levied a 20 million dollar fine on North
stream tubes financing company
reportedly because the proper documents
weren't submitted my opinion no suit you
cannot be stopped because it's so
developed it's developing in the way
that actually make it possible to put a
halt now however there is a chance to
take the profit profitability of its
project down and to make Gazprom well to
operate nothing to harder the Nord
Stream to pipeline could also be used to
transport hydrogen instead of natural
gas experts like high Coloma and say
climate killing greenhouse gases can be
avoided that way if I'm supposed to use
natural gas long term and I'm supposed
to split hydrogen and carbon dioxide
the Russians are working on a process
for making solid carbon so there won't
even be a need for carbon dioxide
storage and I know from koryo she's
interested
that means large volumes of liquid
hydrogen could be transported by Nord
Stream to replacing climate damaging
natural gas it's only a dream of the
future but climate change is
accelerating the process